freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ist sie doch eigentlich
alles ganz normal aus bis man einen
blick auf das hier wird das ist ein
kochbuch das über 100 jahre alt ist ist
aus dem jahre
1904 wir haben das aus der
haushaltsauflösung von einem ganz alten
herren gekauft und wenn man sich schon
das cover design anschaut sieht man dass
das was ganz besonderes nämlich hier mit
cap und so entsprechend angeführt heute
aber das ist wirklich was besonderes ist
somit gold bemalt und man kann leider
nicht mehr drauf lesen wie viel das mal
gekostet hat es ist aber mit ganz großer
sicherheit eine absolute rarität das
gibt es nicht oft und wir leben hier
einmal allgemeines illustriertes
kochbuch führt die deutsche küche vom
deutschen hausfrauen unter mitwirkung
hervorragender autoritäten der koch und
back kunst wären sie wahrscheinlich
heute schon fünfmal für die can send
water von isenburg mitte aber ich sage
ganz ehrlich das ist wirklich was was
schönes und wir gucken einfach mal ein
paar der rezepte an die hier drinnen
genannt sind wir haben hier zum beispiel
die deutsche suppe geben wir auch die
super mehr also es sind auch
verschiedene speisen auch schon damals
aus anderen kulturen vertreten wir haben
hier kräftige brotsuppe für einen
bürgerlichen tisch ganz viele
verschiedene sachen es ist sehr sehr
interessant ich werde auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen rum stöbern aber für
heute haben wir erstmal zwei sachen
rausgesucht die wird interessant
befunden haben ein gericht was wir
ausgesucht haben findet sich hier auf
der seite 206 runter der illustration
von schwein haben wir hier das bier
fleisch ich finde das klingt so richtig
der nach dem 100 jahre alten rezept
einfach immer weiter auf bier fleisch
ist ein gericht mit schweinefleisch ist
ja dass das auch abgebildet wir brauchen
schweine karbonate erstes problem denn
beim metzger angerufen und gesagt habt
ihr schweine karbonat regierung sei was
heute von uns das gibt es heute nicht
mehr diesen begriff also wenn überhaupt
ist er im norden noch ein bisschen
verbreitet ist sind aber im prinzip
komplett also große koteletts von
magerem fleisch also was genau du sagst
du dann haben wir brot kosten zwiebeln
lorbeerblatt pfeffer oder gewürze weil
ich nicht weiß was gewürz ist nimmt man
nämlich pfeffer bier haben wir alles
hier stehen hierzu nimmt man möglichst
magere schweine kardinal es tut in einem
schmortopf einige altem brot kosten
scheiben geschnittene zwiebel
lorbeerblatt ganzen pfeffer und gewürz
abwechselnd mit den kameraden und auch
salz gibt dann über das ganze einfaches
recht schwaches bier kölsch sind das ist
dem fleisch gleich steht das ist auf dem
gleichen level ist wie das verhält und
lässt es so gut zugedeckt langsam
eineinhalb bis zwei stunden schmoren
sollte das bier zu sehr verkopfen
diesmal etwas nach von dem brot wird die
sauce sämig genug wir werden höhe
kartoffel dazu empfohlen wir machen aber
keinen gurkensalat dazu kommen wir
später war der passt sehr gut dazu und
hat auch eine ganz besondere zubereitung
also fangen wir an mit unserem bier
fleisch dies sei ehrlich leute das ist
wirklich eine schöne sache also ist so
ein stück es kultur die man einfach in
seiner hand haben kann und ich bin froh
dass ich das gefunden habe wir haben
keine altes brot bekommen aber wir haben
eine richtig schöne kruste es schneit
dann das innere einfach aus weil nur
brot kosten verwenden das ist hier das
leckerste wurde ist ja wasser aber ich
muss jetzt auch schäbige zwiebeln
schneiden sagt man heutzutage nicht mehr
erscheinen
ich habe hier mal ich finde auch ehrlich
so krass dass mir das vielleicht nicht
mal an rüsten müssen das wäre eigentlich
so ein schritt gewesen so also generell
so von von dialog röstaromen oder zerrte
oder sonst was ist gar nicht so
hervorgehoben was wo man heute immerhin
so rezepte so kleine tricks integriert
wie es halt ein möglichst gutes ergebnis
wird kann mir das hier gar nicht und
deshalb gespannt wie es am ende
schmecken wird es wird wahrscheinlich
sehr sehr einfach sein sofort vom rezept
her auch ich schneide das jetzt sogar
ein bisschen dickere scheiben weil es
ist ja schon gesagt nun etwas derbere
gericht oder somit wir müssen jetzt
nicht so feine die lilien schneiden wir
machen das mit dickeren und diesen
schritt in die rademacher haben menschen
vor über 100 jahren einfach auch schon
gemacht so wir haben unsere schäbigen
zwiebeln hier das heißt der nächste
schritt ist dass wir unsere brot- kosten
jetzt vorbereiten und dafür wirklich
einfach hier so entlang wollen wir das
ganze mal raus wir haben nur noch die
brot größte protest geschnitten werden
noch ein weiteres detail entdeckt wir
wissen auch von dem dieses rezept
geschrieben wurde vor über 100 jahren
nämlich von der frau gertrud guderian
aus görlitz steht darunter der das
rezept aufgeschrieben
slink ist kinderleicht also für das
erste gericht haben wir wirklich an
zutaten nur dass hier das sind die
zutaten fürs erste gericht wir machen
das jetzt nach rezept es tut mir ein
bisschen weh aber ich muss mich als
rezeptteil würde jetzt gerne das fleisch
anrösten und die zwiebeln dünnsten aber
im rezept steht wir tun als erstes die
brotkrumen in unserem kopf dann machen
wir das jetzt
als nächstes die scheiben geschnittenen
zwiebeln heutzutage wird man das glaube
ich landgericht nennen aber gern ferien
wir packen es steht zu diesem rezept die
zwiebeln drauf
wir raten dass man ein bisschen an
resten das brot diensten die zwiebeln
es sieht doch nicht so krass aus man
sollte ehrlich sagen was passiert jetzt
auch nichts mehr filme als auch nicht
sicher ob so sachen wie das anrufen und
so selbstverständlich waren aber ich
glaube eigentlich nicht weil dann
bräuchte man ja kein kochen und dann
geht es auch schon weiter mit dem
nächsten zutaten weil das alles sport ja
das kommt ja relativ lange deshalb
wird's hoffentlich trotzdem alles wieder
zusammen kommen bei denen wir unsere
karbonaten also unsere koteletts geben
wir hinein macht schon sinn dass ernst
roth und zwiebeln drin sind dass sie
nicht direkt das den boden berühren er
das macht sinn oder eben auch nicht so
dazu geben wir jetzt sei zwar nicht zu
knapp und ganzen
nicht gemeint sondern im ganzen körnern
soll wenn jetzt noch ein lorbeerblatt wo
ich mich immer fragen was macht so ein
bauwerk das macht soll das machen
eigentlich kann jetzt recht schwaches
bier bis es zum fleisch gleich steht
geld
[Musik]
gleichzeitig war das erste was länger
kopf stellen wie die hitze schon mal ein
bisschen runter dass es so vor sich hin
köchelt fleisch ist früher besoffener
als derjenige der es ist auf jeden fall
vier flaschen bier kommen hier zusammen
dran und die hat würde ich sagen steht
es dem fleisch gleich ein bis zwei
stunden deckel drauf kochen lassen und
dann genießen dürfen komme ich sag dir
ganz ehrlich wenn ich das hier sehe ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen das ist krass
wird aber wer weiß vielleicht werde ich
überrascht geschmäcker waren auch früher
anders das stimmt ja auch verschieden
große frische salatgurken weißer pfeffer
pariser essig gibt es nicht mehr haben
wir gesucht habe ich gegoogelt ich habe
sogar so suche parameter benutzt um
irgendwas zu finden keine chance es gibt
einfach im internet nichts zu pariser
essig und da drinsteht pariser s isch ja
ich habe mir meine oma zu erreichen hat
leider nicht geklappt wird es mir
vielleicht sagen können wir haben nichts
heraus gefunden dass wirklich krass das
ist einfach mal vergessene zeit mit
vergessene zutaten besteht hier drin wir
wissen davon kleber nutzen einfach helm
es irgendwie stelle hier pariser chic ev
duh auf dann haben wir hier provence öl
darunter habe ich mir immer vorgestellt
öl mit kräutern der provence gibt es
auch so zu kaufen heute noch und die
zubereitung ist eine ganz interessante
wir zählen nämlich zuallererst ein
reifen diese salatgurken hier und zwar
fein säuberlich das films ohne zwiebeln
schneiden nein aber salat uhr geschehen
ist macht ihr spaß diese gruppen
schneiden wir jetzt in feine scheiben
das sollen credit suisse seien die
scheiben die wir standen so wenn die
guten fertig geschnitten sind machen wir
ein bisschen platz hier und verteilen
sie also möglich noch eine lage gurken
da ist wir machen nämlich jetzt etwas
zumindest für mich relativ unübliches
wir setzen die gleich lassen die dann
gesalzen eine halbe stunde das wasser zu
entziehen dann pressen wir sie ich habe
wirklich keine hohen erwartungen so
einfach wegen der zubereitung aber es
lief fantastisch also wirklich das
lassen wir zu 30 minuten liegen ein
bisschen mehr als eine halbe stunde ist
vergangen man kann ganz gut sehen wie
sich wieso kleine pfützen hier teilweise
wilden auf diesen gurken das entzieht
wirklich das wasser und dadurch kann man
diesen schritten gehen jemand heute
häufig geht dass man das innere raus
kreis wir geben das ganze jetzt in eine
alte serviette und gegeben was da drauf
zu packen wir das ganze und trinken ist
jetzt gut aus
weil ich wirklich richtig ordentlich aus
bringen wenn man das ganze kommt auch
gut was phase also der welt hat ganze
arbeit geleistet dass google wasser
natürlich entfernt und gebe jetzt einen
teil vorbau hinein und dazu drei teile
pariser essig bzw einfach weiß nicht
vielleicht weiß jemand von euch was
paris ist oder die großeltern bin ich
auf jeden fall interessieren dazu geben
wir jetzt etwas feinen zucker
und das zerknautschten wir verkaufen
heißt in dem fall dann verhören ja also
hier auch davon aus ich weiß nicht
besser aber ich versuche das jetzt
gucken wir uns unsere gurken an wir
hätten schon ihre farbe burda style
gesehen fast aus wie so
eine besondere besonders viel farbe
dadurch noch irgendwie gegeben jetzt
dazu das sieht aus wie ein richtig guter
gestalter den lassen wir jetzt natürlich
noch ein bisschen marinieren und würzen
das ganze davor mit weißem pfeffer sagt
ehrlich ist ein richtiger oma salat also
hinter aber kräuteröl ist auch schön
dass mir zum stehen und zieht jetzt
müssen wir bei unseren biofleisch
hineingucken ich weiß gar nicht was hier
abgegangen ist hier drin und ich bin
gespannt gucken wir ein tor wo mein gott
was ist denn der hochaltar horst richter
kraft es riecht wirklich so heftig ist
nicht so dollar auch bekannt aber es
riecht nach nach nach brauhaus nach oma
nach gutbürgerlicher küche aber die ist
man das denn ist man das mit diesem
glück bringen roth stückchen ich glaube
heutzutage würde ich das mit einem
pürierstab durchziehen damit man so
vielleicht eine sämige soße art müssen
zu essen ja aber vielleicht auch
manchmal so durchschlagen weil ich sage
ja auch das ist eine sämige soße wird
wir überlegen wie wir das ganze machen
aber ich denke es ist so in zehn minuten
fertig weitere 15 minuten sind vergangen
ist riecht wirklich sehr sehr gut aber
ob es auch schmeckt und ob es gut
aussieht sehen wir jetzt 118 jahre ist
es her dass diese rezepte aufgeschrieben
wurde oder herausgebracht wurden ich
habe hier folgen entstehen bier fleisch
und gurkensalat rein optisch würde ich
sagen ist der gurkensalat leicht
überlegen wie ihr vielleicht wirklich
nicht besonders appetitlich aus wir
haben hier diese mittlerweile ganz weich
gewordene brot kruste wir haben ja nicht
dass man ein bisschen zur seite
schaufele wirklich eine nahtlose stück
fleisch hier das jetzt nach den zwei
stunden hier raus gekommen ist aber bei
uns verwahrt das war zu erwarten ist
wurde ja quasi das würde geschmort darin
aber schneidet das ganze ist macht
wochen segel messer für eigentlich also
durch
besser als erwartet hätte ich habe
absolut gar nicht so erwarte ich habe
erwartet dass es grauenvoll ist aber es
schneidet sich sehr schwer aber die
zähne kommen doch ganz gut damit zurecht
wie es denn geschmacklich abgesehen
jetzt von der etwas zähen textur weil
der geruch hat uns ja schon überzeugt
das ist sehr erzählt die soße die brühe
selbst schmeckt super gut also dass bier
gibt eine feine mit rein ist es gar
nicht so dominant schmeckt er nach so
einer schönen kräftigen brühe problem
ist dass wirklich zu einem du hast ja so
dieses zähe fleisch gut die ganzen
anderen sachen die auch durchaus super
sind wie brotkrumen sind hat wie so ein
pudding geworden aber die zwiebeln dazu
die auch eingekocht sind die kriegt man
geschmacklich nur mit rein wenn man sie
auch mit auf der gabel hat das fleisch
hat jetzt nicht großartig geschmack
angenommen wir haben uns jetzt ja auch
superdome gestellt wir haben nichts von
unseren eigenen wissen angewandt ich
hätte jetzt eigentlich durch den mixer
gezogen hätte das ganze irgendwie ein
bisschen immobilien und mehr zu einem
werden lassen können aber ich wollte es
genauso machen wie es geschrieben ist
und der gurt ist echt lecker
diese kräuter notwehr ins schöne effekte
super frisch diese methode mit dem
ausbringen nicht ob das auch etwas was
man mehr oder weniger genau so jetzt
auch noch gekommen der rente und das
spricht ja auch für ein gerät das
während super so gut über den ich mich
sofort wenn wir irgendwo bekommen wir
dann das fleisch ist durchgefallen also
leider wächst durchgefallen bei mir wenn
man hätte es anbraten können interest
darum drin haben man hätte es eine
schonende garen können als einheit
stunden durch kochen man hätte ein
bisschen fett durchsetzen dass
freischwimmen können das wäre geschmack
nicht alles besser gewesen aber es sind
auch andere zeiten gewesen da hat man
halt genutzt was man hatte ein schönes
schloss fazit ist dass es teilweise sinn
macht sich auch traditionen zu besinnen
und das auch andererseits schönes dass
man fortschritte gemacht hat
nichtsdestotrotz wir durften hier gerade
ein bisschen rum was ein sehr
interessantes video und sehr interessant
das experiment ich freue mich dieses
buch hier noch weiter zu erkundigen
zugleich mahnt aber ich glaube das würde
die
herausgeber nicht mehr dokumente zum
pressen dank fürs zu sehen und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder